this is a story of amyotrophic lateral
sclerosis known as ALS or sometimes MND
and how researchers and people with this
terminal disease leave a legacy for
future generations
[Laughter]
I was seven years old so my dad got
diagnosed in 97 he's in a wheelchair for
quite a while before his voice started
to really go and then he started to use
a light writer to communicate after that
so I don't really remember I don't have
a memory of him communicating and
talking to me kind of in in the flesh
which is a strange
M&D or ALS is the progressive
degeneration of the motor neurons
there's a lot of variability in the age
of onset there's a variability in the
site of onset so it might start with a
weakness in the hand or in the leg and
with difficulty swallowing or speaking
there are kind of like gradual losses so
you know initially there are losses with
walking or your hands or your speech so
you gradually have times going to get
used to those things but like with most
things you only you don't miss until
it's really gone and yeah we didn't
think about recording his voice because
it wasn't even thought about at that
time
[Music]
[Music]
and there's probably a three-second gap
where he's breathing into it trying to
figure out which button to press to save
it and that's the end of it yeah my
first memory of it being really
important to me was coming home from
school and dad was in hospice by this
point somebody had just frames the house
and I so I just caught the tail end of
the answer phone message of him I
figured out that you could press a
button on it and it would replayed this
message so you know just listen to that
quite a number of times repeatedly just
to hear his voice because it was a way
to remember what he used to sound like
and obviously once he did die again I
was it was really important for me as
well to keep hearing his voice in the
terms of my researches I've wanted to
try and understand what's been going
wrong in the motor neurons there's
multiple different reasons why they may
be dying
if you imagine a motor neuron the cell
body can actually be in the base of your
spine and the length of the axon goes
all the way down your leg and may be
controlling the muscle that moves your
big toe so that's an enormous cell when
we actually think of cells normally as
being sort of microscopic so it just
goes to show how challenging these
neurological diseases are when I started
doing the PhD here I knew I want to do
something that was going to help young
people they're being in a similar
situation to me so I started to think
about what had helped me the research is
about people recording a video legacy so
that it could be purposely I've given to
a child a young person in the family to
use in the future so I means that once
they've gone the child a young person as
a way to kind of replay a message in
video form to remember the person that's
passed away it's just kind of
revolutionary for them as it was for me
to kind of look back and see the person
or hear the person as they once were
this is Dean one thing your site's you
too is a love atop you because of where
he do
Dean was diagnosed in May 2013 and uses
a legacy video app could record me now
to leave messages for his friends family
and young children scared walking down
you ought to marry you mum but again to
escape erase the best thing ever did I
was scared to have children as soon as
you have children you never stop being
scared or what it scared make you alive
sorry
pricey use ik never lady stop yeah
because the most successful people in
life I've been scared but they overcome
one of the things I was drawn to
actually was the challenges and there's
a lot of challenges for people with MND
not only have you got the challenges of
making sure that you're ready to think
about the fact you're going to die and
accepts that and really and thinks
yourself that you want to create this
digital legacy it's really quite a short
window where people are physically able
to do it cuz they've still got their
voice and perhaps use technology but
they may not be kind of mentally ready
to get into that place yet to actually
get down and start the ball rolling it
and start doing it it's really hard you
have to think about the messages that
you want your child to know in the
future because you're not going to be
able to say it you having to think about
who you're communicating to because your
knowledge is your child at a young age
but it might be that the video that
you're recording is for them when
they're a lot older getting married or
something
so you're having to think about what
that person might be like in the future
the patient population is so supportive
in participating in the trials they are
continually aware that they may be
giving samples that ultimately may not
be
the findings will not be of benefit to
them but they may be a benefit to their
the next generation
yes seemingly there's quite a sense of
achievement that people have been able
to create something in a time when they
aren't able to do a lot of things that
used to be able to do it's quite a gift
for the young person especially a lady I
had was touching my nose with my tongue
can you do that I feel how special am i
a lot of times when people are on camera
people want to be a polished version of
themselves and that's not all people
young people especially want to see they
want to see the real person I remember a
time where I was trying to go further
along in the tape I remember he had
problems in recording the message so I
was hoping either to hear him swear or
something like that just to just to hear
that aspect of my dad it's not just
about creating a purpose for legacy it's
just about having some sort of legacy in
general I think this has been the
hardest thing I've ever done in my life
trying to find the white buzz I wanna
thank each and every person that has
ever helped or supported us during this
time and I just want to say I know
you're taken case morning
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]